طيب هذه القوه اللي استمدتها هذه الانظمه
يعني هذا يعني انها شديده القوه من اين من
اين اتت هذه القوه قوتها قوتها يعني غالبا
اجت من عناصر كثيره
اول عنصر من العناصر
وتحالفت مع تفتت المجتمعات وزادت بها
التفتت يعني نحن لما اخذنا استلالاتنا كان
في عنا انقسامات
طائفيه دينيه دينيه الى اخره كان في فرصه
لتقريب هالفجوات او رقبها الصدوع بحدود
معينه لو نشات انظمه اكثر عدل اكثر حريه
اللي حصل ولا سيما انه على الانظمه تماهت
مع جماعات طائفيه او اثنيه ببلدانها
وقمعت الحياه السياسيه والتعبيريه
هالشيء ادى لتفاقم التفاوت بدل ما
نعم راب الصدور الصدوع الكبيره هي الحليف
الاساسي الذي بحول اي ثوره او اي انتفاضه
بعد فتره لحرب اهليه لحرب اهليه حيث جزء
من المجتمع اللي هو يختلف او طائفيا او
دينيا عن هويه الحاكم جزء من المجتمع بسور
جزء من المجتمع بيوقف مع النظام لانه بخاف
من
الشيء الثاني الاساسي برايي هو انه
هالتخلي عن مواجهه المشكلات الفعليه الى
المجتمعات
اللي هي اساسا بناء وحدات وطنيه او
التخفيف من الفجوات الاجتماعيه الكبرى
بدل
الانهماك والانكباب مش بس الانظمه حتى
المسقفين بدل الانكباب على مواجهه المشكله
صار في هروب ايديولوجي صار في هروب
بشعارات او انها غير قابل للتحقيق او انها
ماسويه من نوع انه صار اي بلد من البلدان
بده يعمل وحده عربيه وبده يبني الاشتراكيه
وبده يحرر فلسطين
الى اخره
فصنعت انصنعت ثقافي
من جهه هي هروب من مواجهه مشاكل الفعاليه
للمجتمعاتين هي طريق قصير
لمعيسي معيسي قد تكون معارك حربيه
ماسي قد تكون مشاري مثل مشروع الوحده
السوريه المصريه المصريه
وافكار المجتمعات يعني مثلا لما حطينا او
هاي الانظمه العسكريه حطت التنميه تنميه
عبر الدوله وسمتها اشتراكيه حطتها محل
الحريه
ادى لفعلا محطه تحرير فلسطين
لهجره بالكافيهات هائله ما قدرت مجتمعاتنا
تعوضها فيما بعد
ولافقار الافقار المجتمع على كل اصعده على
كل الاصعده صلاه السبعه وستين صارت 67 كنت
مناسبه لمراجعه هالاساسيات اللي
حكمت المرحله 52 الى 67 اوكي صار مراجعات
كبيره بس ولا مره الا هالمراجعات كانت
بمعنى ما
كانها عم تقول بدنا الغلط اللي وصلنا لهون
بنسبه اعلى يعني
الاشتراك عبد الناصر مش كيف بدنا اكثر
اصلاح الخطا بالخطا السياسي مش كيفي بدنا
اكثر
ولا مره صار في مراجعه فعلا ردكاليه
بالكامل
للمسار اللي وصل لل 67 واذا بعده مستمر
يعني كل ما يؤبد ويطيل من عمر هذه الانظمه
هي اشتغلت عليه اشتغلت واستفدت منه يعني
حتى حتى الكوارث الطبيعيه بالاخر اللي عم
تصير صحيح ايضا تستثمر لتابيد هذا النظام
صحيح جدا صحيح جدا الى حد انه
ببين وكانه الكرسي الطبيعيه
اجت هيك امتداد طبيعي
للكوارث القائمه